Our next speaker
is Susan Holmes,
It's a great pleasure
to have her today.
She's a professor at Stanford,
she's very interested in
developing new computational and
statistical approaches to
a rather complex
biological data sets.
And today, she's going to tell
us about challenges posed by
genealogy of human microbiome. Thanks.
>> Okay, thank you.
Thank you for inviting me.
Only invite me to
Boston in October,
that's all I have to say.
I lived here for three years.
Okay, so I got really
interested in microbiome about
more than 10 years ago.
And the challenge here is,
multi domain data.
And that's really what
I'm interested in,
that is heterogeneous data.
Are challenge of everything that
we're doing today in biology,
that is we're trying to combine
not just one source of data.
People talk about big data,
I'm not interested in that.
I think that the multi
domain is the challenge.
And the data I'm gonna talk
to you about today comes from
several projects that
I'm involved in.
[COUGH[ I have a large grant
with David Relman to study
resilience an perturbation in
the human microbiome and I also
work on the March of Dimes
study of preterm pregnancy.
And so we're trying to look at
perturbations on longitudinal
data.
And I'll explain a little
bit some of the challenge.
A lot of them have to do with
the quality of the different
types of data that come in,
the different types of noise,
the graph and tree integration.
And elements that usually
you couldn't just put in
a Euclidean distance
in a standard way.
And then, I'm very wedded
to reproduce ability, so
all of my code, and all the data
I'm gonna talk about that's been
published which is already
publicly available.
So what are the data.
So happily, we already had
the talk at lunchtime about
the human microbiome and the
biota, and so I want to talk.
I agree completely that it's
the place where medicine meets
ecology.
I think that's
an interesting explanation.
And the different types
of data that we have come
at different levels.
There's one gene which is
called the 16S rRNA gene,
which serves as a signature
fingerprint for
all the different
species of bacteria.
And so that's one which
we concentrate a lot on.
There's also the fact that
you can just shotgun and
sequence everything that's there
and look at all the genes.
And that's called
the metagenome.
And you can do what we do
on other types of data,
RNA seq to see what's expressed
by all these different genes.
And we do a lot of mass spec as
well to look at the proteomics.
And then there's a lot of
clinical variables and
environmental variables which
are really important like diet
and time, seasonal effects and
things like that.
We have a lot of domain
knowledge that you can't
just ignore.
So some people feel as if
in order to be objective,
you have to be dumb.
And so you have to pretend
that you only know one
thing at a time.
And that is just a big mistake,
so
you're throwing out
a lot of information.
And you want to take into
account everything you know
in the way you
analyze the data and
that's one of the things
that we really try to do.
That is integrate networks or
phylogenetics trees into
the way that we compare things.
And I like that here there
hasn't been a single talk
where people have
talked about meta data.
They talk about phenotypes and
I'm with you.
That is, there's a whole field
of bio informatics who've left,
who let then and say,
carry on with their metadata.
And this isn't really data.
Everything you collect is data
and you have to integrate it.
So we have to find out how
to combine the data
of different types.
We've written a computational
system around our
own bio conductor which makes
heterogeneous data objects where
you don't lose any of the links.
Between the clinical variables,
the phylogenetic tree, the taxa,
the samples across time, and
that's been very important.
From a more mathematical
point of view and
since we're trying to
look at the computations,
I think it's useful to think
about many of these data sets.
Although it's not economical for
graphs for instance but
think about them as matrices.
So you have many matrices,
you might have time series
the same subjects overtime,
so you can consider the most
matrices of counts.
You might have
posterior distribution,
there's many matrices overtime.
Networks and longitudinal
studies they're still matrices,
it's a good way of thinking
about them mathematically.
And this data is always finite,
so we don't have to do too
much infinite matrices.
Now I brought up in
a French dogma, and
so I'm gonna make you
support it for a few minutes.
I don't think like
a probabilistic maths
statistician, I'm
a data analysis and
I think about everything
geometrically.
So for me,
we have two jewel spaces.
You have the space
of the variable say,
abundances of taxa and all
the samples lie in that space.
And then you have the other side
of things where you can look at
the variables, as measured for
each of the different samples.
Now that duality is
actually useful.
We create inner products
on both spaces and
you just decide which
space you care about and
often it's by cheating
on the dimension.
That is you look at
the dimension which is very
large and
you're going to that's not the
dimensionality of your problem.
If you only have 50 samples the
dimensionality can't be bigger
than 50.
So when people say,
we have 40,000 variables,
yeah but it's still six and 50
dimensions, so you don't have to
worry about having so
many things you're measuring.
It just depends on what
projection you make.
But if you use any kind
of spectral method or
kernel methods,
that actually matters.
It brings down
the dimensionality.
So we have a geometrical
approach to that and
we can put metrics on, and
this really matters when
you do data integration.
You have to care about
how information,
how much waiting you're putting
on all the different variables,
cuz they're going to
have a different effect.
And if you feel as if
you know in one domain,
you have much more information
then in another domain,
you want to take
that into account.
This is a little bit similar
to if you have high variance,
high variability,
on one variable,
you may not want to make exactly
all the variances be one.
So the rescaling of the tables
and rescaling of the variables,
they are a little bit similar,
it's just in spades
in some ways.
So the standard methods and
many people who've talked here.
We already talked about PCA and
dimension reduction.
They're all based on,
you've taken in a product,
you take the eigendecomposition
of the cross product matrix.
And then you take a couple
of eigen functions and
you project the data down.
Now you might do that
in different ways, but
basically that's
a simple framework.
And so
I call that generalized PCA, but
this is very standard and
very easy to do on the computer.
And what we're going to try and
do is change a little bit
the metrics that we put in,
the s and the v that are here.
And we're going
to change them so
that we integrate more
information about
the relationships between
the variables that we get.
So this is the duality
diagram we call.
And this is why you
can go back and
forth, as I was saying before,
between which of
the operators you diagonalize,
and it doesn't.
Just to say that you can frame
many of the standard statistical
methods in this same way.
So one of the interesting ones,
and one which we'll extra plate.
In some sense,
it is discriminant analysis.
So discriminant analysis isn't
the same as PCA just in the fact
that you don't look for
the directions,
the eigenvectors that
maximize the simple variance.
You want to maximize the
variance between the groups and
you're given the group
variability.
And usually you're given
labels for the groups, and
you just want to try and
spread out those labels.
So you can actually write down
the discriminant analysis and
that's useful.
In some way as
a decomposition with the same
community of diagram.
Is just you have a different
metric and you have a metric for
instance to takes into account,
here we have a total
variation and
then you have the winning class
variation which also occurs.
And then we're going to just
diagonalize the different
matrix, and we have
a different waiting scheme.
But you can think of
discriminant analysis
as a special case of PCA.
I want to do something
a little bit different.
I want to not completely take
perfect groups into account.
I have groups that
appear along a tree.
So I'm going to do something
a little bit more sophisticated. Yep?
>> [INAUDIBLE] Analysis or
the other way around?
>> Yes, the other way around.
So discriminant analysis is a
special case of generalized PCA.
Discriminant analysis is
eigen decomposition and
you can put in the weight here.
This triplet here.
So that this is a PCA but
it gives you
the discriminant variables.
And if you could think
about it this way.
Think that you're giving
special weights and
you take the mean points of
each of the groups and you do
PCA with regards to that and
you have a special weighting.
And it's, that's the same thing.
But it's useful when you want
to go to sort of intermediary.
So as I said, we're going to
look at many matrices overtime
and here I've put in here,
some of the information that
we'd like to take into account.
So for the taxa, the different
species we know phylogenetic
trees these are given to us.
For genetic networks,
we have genetic interactions,
we have protein-protein
interactions or genetic
reactions that we can induce and
we already know.
And when you're doing functional
data, for instance, if you have
mass spec metabolite data,
you know the metabolic network.
So we actually want to use
metrics which take all
of those into account.
The earliest way
of doing this was
to say everything
is distances and
if we can make the right
distance, then we can make
low dimensional representation
of these distances.
And this actually came from
the work of Schoenberg.
And the idea there is to say,
you're given a matrix it's
symmetric positive numbers.
We're going to find the points
in Euclidean space which have
distances which are as
close as possible, so
those given distances.
And so that method is called
multi dimensional scaling in one
world it's called PCoA
in the world of ecology.
And that's been the workhorse
of most of the early work
on microbial ecology
is based on this PCoA.
Now the secret sauce here is
the distance that is you have
to choose a distance which
is relevant to your data.
So people use Bray Curtis
distance, there are actually 40
different distances from
which to choose from.
So it's quite troubling
because in some sense,
you already have to know
what you're looking for,
there's some metric learning
inference in there.
When you are choosing
your distance.
But there is a way to take into
account the distance on the tree
between the species and then
doing a PCoA on those points.
So the way that works and
this is called double principle
coordinate analysis and
that was first developed by
ecologist and my PhD student,
Elizabeth Purdum,
developed it for the microbiom.
And that's that you're
given the samples are at
different locations say,
and those
locations you have measurements
of abundances of all the taxa.
And you have a tree
relationship between the taxa.
So you start taking the distance
on the tree between the species.
You build a coordinate space,
Euclidean.
And then you take the points,
the abundances as the weights
on the coordinate spaces.
And so
that's a little bit abstract,
let me show you on an example
but that's the idea,
it's called double principle
coordinate analysis.
So this is what it looks like
on antibiotic time course data.
So in this first preliminary
study that David Relman did.
There were three subjects and
there were about
2,500 different taxa
that were measured on 50 time
points on these three subjects.
We're trying to understand
the time points corresponded.
There were two courses
of antibiotics.
I'm trying to understand
the resilience,
that is some of the subjects
change under antibiotic stress
the abundances of the bacteria.
And so the way that I just said,
we take the or
the relationship between the
different taxa which is known.
And you can make
a multidimensional scaling,
a PCoA of those points and then
take each of these points and
their abundances, and
take those as the weights.
And then you get
a representation of all
the samples.
So the first thing you see here
is the green, the red, and
the blue.
The colors are all
the different subjects.
The best things about
the microbiome is the only thing
that matters if you're trying
to differentiate is the person.
Every person has their own
ecology, there are lots of
degrees of freedom and
we're all very different.
So, that is the main motivation
why all the studies I'm going to
show you are longitudinal,
that is you can only really
use the personal as their own
control when you're doing
a perturbation study.
And this is the relationship
that we see, now what I want to
show you really is what
happens with the perturbation.
So under stress, I'm gonna make
some of those samples be of
one type,
those would be the stress,
that is when they're taking
antibiotics and just after.
And the other will be
what happened before and
a long time after
the antibiotics.
So the E1 is under stress and E2
is when they're back to normal.
So what you see is
within each subject,
so the subject to
subject differences.
But there is a tendency for
these two subjects to
have the same direction,
they shifted in the same way so
the stress seems to be the same.
Here we had a particular
type of subject who was.
Didn't react.
So wasn't resilient
in the same way.
And so, these representations
enabled us to see, well,
there's something to be studied
about what they do together,
what is common to the subjects.
And some of the subjects,
one group of subjects sort of
don't seem to show
much difference.
So we did a larger study, and
I'm gonna show you that now.
And this study just appeared
in August in
Plus Computational Biology.
And here what we
wanted to do was adapt
the DPCoA to be less severe.
That is, in some sense, we don't
believe that the only component
variants, the only thing
that's moving the variability,
is the phylogenetic tree.
We believe that evolution and
the tree between the different
taxa is important.
But we believe there's a whole
part of the variability which
isn't linked to the tree.
So we wanted to
modulate the tree.
And so this is a sparkline plot.
In fact, every line that's
coming out of this is a time
series, and I'll give
you a better plot of it.
But this is the phylogenetic
tree of the different taxa that
are found.
So first of all, this is
a small part of a larger study.
Here, we only have
eight patients.
We actually have
100 subjects that
we recruited through
the Quantified Self.
So wonderful method for
recruiting subjects,
the Quantified Self.
Big problem,
not a good demographic sample,
the Quantified Self.
It's young men between
the age of 25 and 35.
We had more than 100
people of these type sign
up within the first week.
And then we had to say, no, no,
we don't want any more of you.
[LAUGH] Because usually
recruitment is a big problem.
So we were very excited to
begin with all these people
recruiting.
Then we look at the profiles and
they're completely homogeneous.
[LAUGH] So
this is a subset of them.
And these canonically
announce that the subject
volunteered to do.
And they were, as you see,
the time points are not
equally distributed.
That is,
we have very heavy density in
sampling around
the perturbation.
So that's a carefully
designed statistical study.
In some sense, that is,
in statistics,
when you make an experimental
design, you always collect
more points where you have high
variance, so high perturbation.
And then outside we have more
regularly sampled points.
And this is not antibiotics.
We have several runs
of perturbations for
the same subjects.
This is just a canonic T-null.
So here we actually,
mathematically,
constructed a prior which
was in between the tree
and just having an ordinary
variance/covariance matrix.
And the way we did it is
by constructing a kernal.
And in order to make a kernel
which sorta obeys a tree,
we took Brownian motion.
And if the correlation
is very high,
we suppose that along
the Brownian motion,
the particles sustain
the same along the same path.
And then when they're
splitting off,
then they become independent.
They're losing their dependency.
So the length of the branches
high up in the tree
tells you how correlated
the variables are.
So this is quite a realistic
model for a phylogenetic tree
but it enables us to build,
in some sense, this kernel.
And I won't [INAUDIBLE].
Yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE] structure?
>> So the nodes here are going
to be the taxa, yep.
And so we're going to build a
metric such that the covariance,
in some sense, is, if the taxa
are right down to the bottom
of the tree together, they're
going to be very correlated.
But that's the idea.
But we actually,
how can I say it?
We put a weight on the part
of which was the ordinary
variance and the part which
is actually the tree.
So you can modulate.
This is like a one
parameter family that goes
from ordinary PCA all
the way to DPCoA.
So you can modulate, and you can
actually get the data to tell
you what the ideal
tuning parameter is.
And this is called
adaptive generalized PCA.
And it's Julia Fukiyama
who wrote,
there's a program on
GitHub that you can use.
And, yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE] tell you with
respect to what objective?
>> Sorry, would it be a metric?
>> No, with what objective,
when you say let the data tell
you where to interpolate
between those two?
>> Well, you can look at
the different criteria.
You can do it by
cross-validation or you can do
it with regards to some other
information that you have.
In this case, we actually have
a change point which we know.
As I say, I'm not
an objective statistician.
I refuse to be dumb.
So I know something
about this data.
I know when we gave
the cleanout to the subjects.
So if we can find a change point
which is coherent with our data,
that's what I'm looking for.
And this is the output.
So here's the phylogenetic
tree of the different taxa.
These are coefficients which
actually correspond to the taxa,
and they appear on the branches.
It's a little bit
hard to see here.
But here is how these different
taxa jump up and down.
And so, here you can see that
this RSV305 goes way down
during the perturbation and then
reestablishes itself perfectly,
so very resilient taxa.
So we have these profiles
of these different taxa.
And we could see,
that's what we're interested in.
So that enables us to see that.
So I can't give you all
the details in the paper.
We have a Docker image and
three bioconductor packages
in the dataset which are all
public, which go with the paper.
So I encourage you to ask
me questions offline or
by email if you want
to try this out.
I do think it's
really important to
say that everybody could have
come up with a different method.
We could have done
different types of models.
And it's interesting to
compare between methods.
And so I'm open to other
people analyzing the data and
telling me, you got that
completely wrong, and so on.
So we do try to make a
reproducible research workflow.
And you saw these RSVs,
and in fact,
what they are, I've changed
the names from OTUs.
So my field,
we often call them OTUs.
There's been a big mistake
made in defining the unit,
the strains with which we work.
And I took OTUs to
be standard and
I didn't ask how this raw data
was profiled at the beginning.
And I realized that there
had been a mistake.
And so I'm gonna talk to you a
little bit about what we did for
this mistake.
And this is about data two.
And so if you want to see
exactly how you use all of this
data two, we did make a complete
workflow in F1000Research,
which has the code.
So the strain-level analysis,
and
this came up in the talk
that Oleg gave this morning,
that we'd like to know more
about certain strains.
And I'll just motivate it and
tell you why.
We did two studies on pregnancy
and I'm predicting preterm.
And the main thing that came out
when we did these studies was
that there are certain taxa
which came out as really
important.
And the main one that
came out was Gardnerella.
And we were able to
revisit the data.
And actually we took a class
of subjects, so different
ethnicity, different background,
and we found the same results.
But we also found that it wasn't
all the strains of gun they're
out of that were associated
with preterm births.
So that was that something
that was important for us.
And that's why it's sort of the
attention to detail in this case
is very important.
So here,
there's Gardnerella screening.
We were able to do it by
ignoring what I said about
distances.
So distances, forget all
the beginning of the talk.
I said distances were
really important.
Distances aren't everything.
And this is a mistake that
we made doing OT use.
So it's much better to
have strain information
than not have strain
information here.
When you follow
the different women,
you can see that the strains
stay about the same.
But we don't have the strain
resolution when you use the old
method.
So how do people build
what are called OTUs?
They use a distance.
And so if you have strains which
occur 100 times more than other
strains, the OTU method
take a radius of
a fixed distance, which doesn't
take into account the frequency.
And that's a bad
kind of distance.
You want a distance which tells
you whether you have, and
this is what annoys me when
people compare women and
men in Math,
Larry Summers and so on.
The thing is, if you don't
have the same number of
baseline people you're comparing
to, of course if you have 10,
000 men, you have much
higher extreme points.
If you have a hundred women,
you're gonna have much
less extreme points.
So, the frequency on
the line is not independent.
The extreme points are not
independent of the frequencies,
and this is a mistake that
everybody seems to make.
And so, this was a mistake
that people made on OTUs.
And we modeled the frequencies,
taking into account that
some of the OTUs, some of the
strains are much more frequent.
You're going to see many more
errors if they're much more
frequent.
And if you take
that into account,
we have this error model and
we were able to, sorry.
I'm gonna go back to show
you what this gave us.
This comes from this new
probabilistic error model
in which we've incorporated
the frequencies
with which you see the strains.
And we're able to denoise, if
you have a strain which occurs
a 100,000 times, you're going
to see, with some error,
five errors away will be
quite frequent within that.
And if you have a sequence which
is five away, it's probably just
a noisy version of your
very frequent sequence.
So this method has completely
changed how we're able to do
the straining.
And I wish we could do it for
metagenomics and
if anybody is interested in
doing a really hard project.
It would be to take this,
what we've done for one gene and
do it for
a whole set of marker genes.
And so that's a paper that
appeared in Nature Methods with
Ben Callahan.
And I don't have time to tell
you about the registration that
we did to do uncertainty, but
I just show you this picture,
my goal has been that
when we make these
multidimensional dimension
of plots with PCOA.
We don't use ellipses,
the data are never normal.
You can't use ellipses but
you can do Bayesian computations
which give you Bayesian
confidence intervals.
And here we have confidence
regions around points by using
Bayesian posteriors and it's
much better than just trying to
say everything is normally
distributed which it's not.
So I'm going to finish.
Thank all the statisticians who
make all their data available in
bio conductor because
I use it a lot.
We have a lot of different
GitHub repos, and
everything to do with phyloseq
developed by Joey, and
he has very good tutorials.
I work mostly with David Relman.
And Elisabeth Purdom
is the first person I
worked with on the microbiome.
And these are other
people who do proteins,
that's my lab group, and
I'm hiring a post Doc.
And I know you can't come from
statistics because there is no
such thing, but if you come
from physics I will take you.
Ben Callahan I think
the physicists
are the donor model for
people who [LAUGH].
Okay that's enough.
[LAUGH] Thank you, that's good.
>> [APPLAUSE]